[Music]
this morning the adele of audiobooks
that was the name given to julia whalen
by the new yorker she is one of the most
famous audiobook narrators in the world
as the business of listening to books
instead of reading them keeps rising
but whalen a former child actress is
more than just a performer on tape she's
also a writer she just released her
second book called
thank you for listening to hear how she
does it we sat down with her and jumped
in the booth for some dueling narration
at her home in california
audiobooks
roy's eyebrows shot up dude that's my
jam you have almost certainly heard
julia whalen's voice before elsa went
back to scrubbing the kitchen floor
it's possible she spent extended periods
of time in your head and as if across
miles she heard annika bergstrom say
mrs abbott she is a trusted companion to
millions
bringing spoken performance to the
written word i know there are those
among you who could use some
reacquaintance with the language i
didn't think you were ever going to find
me waylon first showed up on camera at
11. why don't we play a game you want to
play and was a tv star by 15.
acting for three seasons in the abc
drama once and again
you're gonna do what you do anyway and
it's really okay with me but please
don't act like you're giving me some big
say in any of it
weyland's on-screen work continued
before and after college
until it was her work off screen that
took her in a new direction
a producer asked if she wanted to
narrate a new suspense novel
gone girl she sent an email asking if i
wanted to do it but warning me that it
was a bit r-rated which in hindsight is
funny because that's i don't think of
that book being that way but i was
recording so much young adult at the
time
that i think she thought i would say oh
this is a little dark
and instead i was like give it to me
that's awesome i love this so much
it is dark it's so dark but it's so good
gone girl became a mega best seller and
helped establish weyland as an audiobook
star
soon she was recording 70 to 80 books a
year
where would you like me to start i asked
lately she's dialed her narration back a
bit to about 30 books a year
so she can also write
whalen's latest which she wrote and
recorded is called thank you for
listening
it features a fictional audiobook
narrator who refuses to do romance books
until her life becomes one
romance books you might be surprised to
hear
make up a third of the global book
market
it's something that people look down on
yeah
why
i don't fully understand why
romance is taken less seriously than
crime or a thriller or mystery where you
have also rather
predictable endings
and they're fan favorites and people
read them voraciously but
just doesn't quite get the respect
because they can still be written well i
mean absolutely there's great writing i
i cut my teeth on romance i mean i
learned i read a lot of romance when i
was younger i learned plot from romance
writers
dialogue from romance writers it is
there's really good writing in romance
here's the booth
maybe it's all the sex that can make
reading it alone thrilling swanny
murmured back with a faintest sensual
giggle maybe lower but with an audience
it's a different ball game we're over we
reading the super sex time
okay
wow okay so hold on let me just
why don't you give me your best brock
mcknight voice
where would you like me to start i feel
good here i tapped her knee with a hand
that wasn't already engaged with her
fingers she shook her head
maybe higher
i removed my hand from her knee and
placed it okay wait
slow down it's a seduction scene okay
yeah okay i'm seducing you're seducing
it turns out seduction
always works better with a partner where
would you like me to start i asked here
i tapped her knee with a hand that
wasn't already engaged with her fingers
she shook her head
maybe higher
i removed my hand from her knee and
placed it on her cheek
i slid my fingers under her chin and
gently raised her head that's good so we
looked each other in the eye yes high
enough
swaney murmured back with the faintest
sensual giggle
maybe lower
that was good thanks right yes you're
good at this
do you like doing the sex
once i got it into my head that that's
really what it is that it's like it's
just a climactic scene in a book it was
easier for me to perform and i do find
it's so hard to do this without
everything sounding euphemistic i do
find satisfaction
in
these scenes being well performed
because
here's the thing about romance like the
other
i think that in romance specifically
the sex scenes and the sexual encounters
are the turning points in the
relationship so that's where the
characters learn something that's where
they grow that's where they change
but you're saying a lot of stuff that's
like i know i saw you laugh at grow
well you can't help i mean like it's
hard like everything you say can be
taken a different way
yes ha
he finger gunned her usually waylon
doesn't need a companion narrator and
then you famous too she does men's
voices a fair bit of overlap in my
experience kids voices do you often find
yourself working with navy seals when i
was 12 i was obsessed and every kind of
accent
bloody hell
you'll be a crampy soon what's your
favorite accent
well it depends i mean i think that i
have i have a lot of fun with regional
american accents what's your favorite
word to pronounce
oh that's a good question i definitely
know the words i don't like to pronounce
the one that trips me up which should
not trip me up but midnight
always coming in the middle of a
sentence i know but coming in the middle
of a sentence it's like i can't get the
i can't get my mouth around the m
and i will almost always yeah now try it
midnight it somehow gets like swallowed
in my in my throat a little bit maybe
you should reconsider becoming a
journalist i feel like romance novels
are your true calling how do you read
and talk that much every day
and never lose your voice
well this comes this is part of the
doing fewer books thing i mean i have
extensive theatrical vocal training um
so i know how to be good to my
instrument and i hit a wall one year
where i had to go on vocal rest for a
month and that was kind of the wake up
call that was like this isn't this isn't
good
green apples green apples
why do green apples help
no one knows that's not true probably
watch all of the
all the viewers would be like i know i
don't know i think it has something to
do with tannins it has something to do
with the acidity i mean apples in
general apple pulp is always good for uh
vocal health but green apples
particularly just crisp everything up
wow jeffrey todd
i feel like i know i'm in a very
different way that i was not expecting
my brock mcknight oh yes wow
she reached over and grabbed the apple
please do your show that way
we've got some green apples for you
how about them apples
to enjoy which now that we're at the end
of the show and your voice doesn't need
to be as strong but anyway so green
apples work right she does not have
dairy
any dairy or milk products on days she
records
so
well
thank you julia the book thank you for
listening is great
[Music]
that was an incredible story i it took
me in so many different ways i can't
even say i've learned so much
this is a really good tip though eating
apples yes yeah i'm gonna keep that in
mind i'm sorry i still can't get over
how
should we have gotten an nc-17
it was morning television jeffrey i'm
certainly awake i was really nervous
going in there i mean
you know because it's her it's her place
right and i yes i track stories and
track pieces all the time
but um it's not it's her environment we
actually ended up tracking the story a
different story from her booth
um you know i track stuff from home all
the time
um but i was nervous but she was very
helpful in sort of coaching me through
it it looked like it was a blast i have
to tell you and just you were a little
it was like cute seeing you embarrassed
a little
you know a little blushing yeah
you know it's also um it's a real art
form what she does because she is
delivering something yes but you don't
want to get lost in someone saying oh
i'm narrating something and her voice is
so soothing and lyrical at the same time
and she does so many different voices
the accents everything else i mean she
really you know it's it's it's she
performs this work and what's even more
impressive is that she has to read it
first by herself and mark it up and
think about the accents and the voices
and everything else and then she reads
it out loud and you're talking about 70
or 80 books a year yeah now we're
cutting those in half
i could talk about her forever